et notre invité politique ce matin ses
jambes est moite bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous secrétaire
d'état chargé du tourisme des français
de l'étranger de la francophonie on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview au partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale dont jean stéphane
bern est bonjour vous les fans qui
dirige le bureau parisien du journal
ouest france et qu on est ravi de
retrouver pour cette nouvelle saison
stéphane on va bien sûr parlé longuement
du tourisme jean m cirmad mais d'abord
quelques questions d'actualité notamment
cette obligation vaccinale qui
s'applique à partir d'aujourd'hui pour
les soignants les pompiers les aides à
domicile
selon santé publique france il serait
12% à être encore non vaccinées dans
aucun schéma vaccinal et qui est ce que
donc la suspension voire le licenciement
est ce qu'on peut se passer d'une partie
de nos soignants dans le contexte actuel
bon déjà quand on est soignant la
moindre des choses c'est de pouvoir soi
même ne pas être un risque pour les
personnes qu'on soigne et c'est pour ça
que cette obligation vaccinale a été
mise en place elle n'a pas été mise en
place en trois jours le discours du
président de république c'est le 12
juillet on est le 15 septembre
donc les gens ont eu le temps de prendre
leurs dispositions maintenant certains
en tireront peut-être des conséquences
dans leur activité professionnelle
ce que j'entends c'est que dans tous les
cas les les hôpitaux les ehpad et
structures ont naturellement
procédé à l'analyse des personnels
éventuellement
réticents à procéder à cette vaccination
et se sont organisés alors ça va être
peut-être un peu plus de travail pendant
quelques temps pour les autres
personnels mais à 90% ils sont vaccinés
et donc les choses quand même s'engage
plutôt bien ils se sont organisés ça va
quand même être compliqué on estime que
5 à 7% des personnels des ehpad et des
services à domicile ne voudront pas du
tout se faire vacciner or ce sont des
maisons ou des services qui sont déjà en
tension au niveau du personnel et qui
ont la troisième injection enfin la
troisième dose de vaccin à gérer pour
leur propre président depuis lundi c'est
quand même très compliqué est ce que ça
ça ça mériterait pas des ajustements par
exemple le gouvernement a décidé de
suspendre l'obligation vaccinale pour le
la guadeloupe et les antilles vous savez
les demandes d'ajustement j'en ai
entendu beaucoup depuis le 2 juillet par
exemple dans un certain nombre de
secteurs
économiques avec lesquels je travaille
dans le secteur du tourisme et c'est
vrai que et bien on a tenu par exemple à
mettre en place ce pass sanitaire dès la
fin juillet dans les pâles dans les
musées
et puis les tendres le 9 août à
l'hôtellerie à la restauration pardonnez
moi et heureusement qu'on l'a fait c'est
ce qui a sauvé la saison alors qu'il y
avait une épée de damoclès est bien de
la même façon on ne peut pas imaginer
que soit en risque des personnes
fragiles parce que justement dans un
ehpad dans un hôpital donc c'est une
mesure de bon sens et mais voilà
j'appelle tous les soignants qui ont
encore éventuellement quelques
questionnements et bien en parler avec
avec leurs cadres à partager des
éléments très objectif très rationnel la
vaccination ça évite très clairement et
ça diminue le risque d'être contaminé le
risque d'aller en réanimation donc
parfois on a l'impression que le
dialogue est compliquée avec des
personnes qui sont partis un peu dans un
monde parallèle quand on regarde des
manifestations du samedi moi je leur dis
vraiment regarder les chiffres les faits
ils sont têtus et il montre que la
vaccination ça marche l'autre actualité
elle concerne notre quotidien notre
porte monnaie c'est celui de décence qui
dépasse les 2 euros qui retrouvent des
niveaux élevés est ce que vous craignez
une nouvelle colère d'une partie de la
population nouveau mouvement piéger les
jeunes alors sur ce sujet montre deux
choses c'est que d'une part ce
gouvernement depuis quatre ans il n'est
pas resté les bras balants 25 milliards
d'euros de baisse de la pression fiscale
ça veut dire souvenez vous la taxe
d'habitation qui était supprimé
c'est faire en sorte que le travail paye
plus la prime d'activité qui a été
augmentée donc nous avons fait pour le
pouvoir d'achat des soignants d'ailleurs
pour le pouvoir d'achat d'un certain
nombre de professions qui sont exposés
mais ce sujet montre aussi une chose
c'est qu'il faut sortir de notre
dépendance par rapport à tout ce qui est
carbone pétrole etc et c'est ce dans
quoi nous sommes engagés ces transitions
regarder le plan de relance 100
milliards d'euros le fil rouge c'est la
transition écologique c'est pour éviter
aussi d'être dépendant de ses ressorts
donc ça va tant qu est ce que vous dites
aux français qui ce mois ci vont voir
leur facture d'essence augmentait ce qui
est des mesures qui vont être prises
pour aider les plus modestes écoutez
encore une fois faut regarder de façon
structurelle tout ce qui est tout
pouvoir d'achat qu'on a données créées
grâce aux baisses de prélèvements grâce
au coup de pouce significatif qui ont
été données à un certain nombre de
catégories et maintenant écouter
naturellement les distributeurs par
exemple je pense serait aussi bien
avisés de pouvoir pendant quelque temps
faire un effort pour pouvoir peut-être
renier des marges sur la vente de ces
deux s'est produit parce que
effectivement et bien la rentrée ben
écoute et on sait que ça peut être un
produit d'appel il ya un moment il faut
aussi quand on fait du pouvoir d'achat
des français est un slogan pour les
attirer dans les magasins et bien faire
que ce soit le cas réellement
dans la dans l'actualité une tête une
question sur le
bobo de la sécurité le président veut
plus de bleus sur le terrain il parle
pas de l'équipe de france
la sécurité ça fait partie aussi des
arguments pour le tourisme notamment
dans certaines villes est ce que ces
annonces la vous paraissent aller dans
le bon sens plus d'argent plus de moyens
le contrôle parlementaire de la police
alors ce sont des annonces qui
s'inscrivent déjà dans une continuité
succès depuis le début du quinquennat
nous sommes un gouvernement qui
justement a par exemple améliorer les
matériels rénover un certain nombre de
commissariats de casernes et c'est aussi
un gouvernement qui a si je puis dire
pas liée aussi aux carences des
gouvernements qui ont précédé souvenez
vous il ya dix ans est bien là
les gouvernements d'ailleurs de droite
avait supprimé plusieurs milliers de
fonctionnaires de police d'une manière
d'une manière générale on peut dire
qu'on a vu disparaître un nombre
considérable de policiers en tenue sur
la voie publique dans les grandes villes
et est donc le président poursuit cet
engagement engagements budgétaires 1.5
milliard d'euros annoncée et puis il va
au delà des mesures d'urgence il ya
aussi un besoin de de repenser l'action
publique mais dans tous les domaines je
pense que il ya besoin de tirer le
meilleur parti des nouvelles
technologies regardez ce chantier de la
plainte en ligne et puis peut-être
travailler sur les missions des
personnels les décharger de certaines
missions pour leur permettre d'être plus
présents sur le terrain c'est très
clairement des attentes bien sûr et on y
travaille donc je crois qu'on est là
dans une une continuité et puis une
accélération aussi on va parler du
tourisme maintenant jamais de slam
annoncé mi septembre quel bilan vous
faites ce matin de la saison estivale
est ce que vous pouvez nous dire c'est
une saison réussie ou pas écoutez j'ai
envie de dire pari réussi parce que
cette saison elle n'avait rien d'évident
dans la mesure où ce variant delta est
apparue souvenez vous fin juin début
juillet et qu' ils auraient pu
compromettre la saison il est apparu un
peu partout en europe et on a réussi
finalement à à faire cette saison dans
de bonnes conditions voire parfois sur
certains territoires et dans certaines
filières une très bonne saison grâce
quel territoire je vais venir j'ai venir
quelle filière grâce à la vaccination
grâce au pass sanitaire grâce aux
professionnels et les en remercie qui
également se sont préparés
minutieusement alors quand on regarde
dans le détail eh bien on est pour
certains pour la plupart des territoires
et la plupart des filières d'hébergement
par exemple avec des résultats
supérieurs à 2010 neuf années qui elle
même était une année historique
je prends par exemple l'hôtellerie de
plein air eh bien il ya eu plus de
français en 2021 qu'en 2019 dans les
campings et ça a même compenser comment
dire la fréquentation qui reste encore
un petit peu en baisse des clientèles
étrangères donc ce sont des signaux très
intéressant à bien fonctionner juste que
c'est l'été bleu blanc rouge qui a bien
marché c'est tout à fait entre 85 et 90
% d'entre eux sont restés sur le sol
national aux consignes de rendez vous
savez je pense que il faut être modeste
mais c'est vrai qu'avec atout france on
a lancé une grande campagne pour
redécouvrir la france et puis aussi pour
appeler les européens proximité à
revenir et qui sont venus s coup s que
les touristes étrangers nous ont manqué
cette saison les européennes proximité
sont venus et ce qui est très
exactement les belges et les allemands
les suisses les néerlandais par contre
d'autres destinations qu'on n'a pas vue
revenir enfin d'autres par exemple
une tendance très intéressante qui
touchent des français comme les
européens c'est que désormais on voyage
plus en circuit court si je puis dire
donc on va moins loin et de ce point de
vue là la france compte tenu à la fois
de son positionnement géographique au
coeur de l'europe et puis de ce qu'elle
offre en matière de patrimoine
d'activité est très attractive et donc
en revanche c'est vrai que les
clientèles lointaines sont moins au
rendez vous
frémissements du côté des américains et
des canadiens
par exemple je peux le voir parce que
cet été nous avons mis en place
notamment une cellule pour faire en
sorte que ces visiteurs internationaux
puissent convertir leur certificat de
vaccination en qr code est donc en passe
sanitaires il y en a vu qu'à 70% ça
concerne l amérique du nord donc cette
clientèle là elle a une envie de france
qui est intacte a néanmoins le fait que
les asiatiques ne soit pas là les russes
ne soit pas là pour un certain nombre de
raisons fait que des destinations comme
paris reste dans des situations
difficiles et notamment au regard du
tourisme d'affaires qui
n'a pas encore repris comme il devrait
ça veut dire qu'il ya des disparités
sont tout à fait méritée quels sont les
territoires où les touristes ont été au
rendez vous et ce à part paris
tous les littoraux traditionnellement
comme traditionnellement ont bien marché
la montagne a été également un tube de
l'été un + 8 % sur les massifs d'après
l'association nationale des stations de
montagne je serai leur assemblée
générale cet après-midi et notamment
plus 25% pour les pyrénées c'est vous
dire que il ya une envie je crois de
s'oxygéner de de s'aérer de de pouvoir
faire justement de la randonnée du vélo
alors heureusement il à l'assistance
électrique parce qu'en montagne voilà
c'est ça peut être dur mais mais mais
donc il ya aussi une diversification de
l'offre proposée par ces territoires
pour essayer de vivre quatre saisons
alors par contre vous vous évoquiez les
difficultés du tourisme d'affaires c'est
par là c'est pas la joie mais vous avez
d'autres secteurs qui ont quand même
forcément souffert des situations je
pense au festival l'événementiel en
général et comment ça se passe également
du côté des grands équipements par
exemple les parcs de loisirs est ce que
la l'application du pacte du pass
sanitaire a eu un très gros impact sur
leur activité cet été ou pas alors c'est
différencier les parcs de loisirs ont
connu l'application du pass à partir du
21 juillet sur la première semaine on a
vu que effectivement ça se traduisait
par des baisses de fréquentation mais
qui tout de suite au bout d'une semaine
dix jours sont repartis à la hausse du
cours dans la saison c'est lycée et l'a
passé à peu près quelques jours dans
l'allier au parc du pal que je
recommande c'est vraiment un outil
formidable mis en place par arnaud
bennet et la famille et ils me disaient
qu'ils ont connus en juillet et en août
des records de fréquentation c'était la
même chose et bien où ça très bien
fonctionné à guédelon dans l'yonne
naturellement chère à mon coeur
donc les vaisseau amiral ont réussi à
tirer leur épingle du jeu maintenant des
plus petites structures
ont pu connaître des baisses de
fréquentation de - 20 - 25 - 30 %
lié en fait à deux choses parce qu'il ya
également une météo maussade il faut se
le voir et donc quand on est en
extérieur forcément ça joue donc mais je
crois qu'il faut il faut distinguer et
c'est pour ça aussi que on reste en
soutien de ses acteurs avec bruno le
maire on a reçu les acteurs économiques
c'était le 30 août au mois de septembre
on a continué avec le fonds de
solidarité qui demeurent en place au
mois d'octobre il ya le dispositif des
coûts fixes qui permet de faire du sur
mesure entre eux pensent pas entre les
fonctionnalités de quoi qu'il en coûte
on a compris ça s'arrête le 30 septembre
eh bien on va sur des aides ciblées et
adaptées à chaque structure c'est ce
qu'on appelle ce dispositif de prise en
charge des coûts fixes qui va permettre
à des entreprises qui connaissent encore
des pertes importantes d'être compensés
sur ses coûts fixes et donc d'avoir un
soutien donc il y en a une clause de
revoyure début novembre donc on continue
à travailler avec tous ces secteurs là
parce que vous prenez par exemple les
agences de voyages elles ont fait un
beau mois de juin mais après variant
delta patatras juillet et août ça a été
plus compliqué il a même fallu rapatrier
des gens dans des circonstances
souvenez-vous en sicile et c'est un peu
compliqué et ce sont des gens qui ont
besoin encore d'un soutien
pascal on a compris les agences de
voyages
il faudrait inviter puisqu'on est en
train d'y travailler qu'avec leurs
représentants il ya notamment le secteur
de l'événementiel et le secteur des
entreprises du voyage avec laquelle on
travaille plus spécifiquement à des
plans d'action l'événementiel on va par
exemple les aider pour bien mettre la
destination france sous les projecteurs
parce qu'il ya des envies de deux
voisins allemands par exemple
de 2,2 de prendre des parts de marché on
pourra très concret et donc avec atout
france par exemple on a lancé une
campagne mon événement en france pour
inciter à la fois à faire venir des
événements en france à faire en sorte
que des exposants viennent dans les
évènements français je serai lundi
prochain avec alain griset à la
rencontre du secteur de l'événementiel
foires et salons on sera à villepinte et
il ya notamment le salon première vision
qui siens donc voyez la marque de
fabrique c'est de travailler à toutes
ces mesures avec les acteurs du secteur
ont co construit et s'est passé pas
quand je dis ça c'est pas du vent c'est
que derrière ça se traduit par depuis le
début de la crise 37 milliards d'euros
mis en place en soutien uniquement au
secteur du tourisme 37 milliards d'euros
donc c'est pas rien est-ce que vous
pouvez vous garantir que nous aurons de
la neige à noël et que les remontées
mécaniques qui seront ouverts cet hiver
écoutez c'est vrai que la montagne
française elle a connu une situation
très compliquée et que le fait qu'on a
pas pu ouvrir et remontées mécaniques à
l'hiver dernier en raison de la
troisième vague qui nous touchait ce qui
est sûr c'est que depuis on a deux
événements nouveaux on a un une
vaccination qui aujourd'hui touchent
très largement les publics de plus de 12
ans prévus 85% de la cible vaccinable
l'est et puis deuxièmement on a appris
le cas échéant parce que pour l'instant
le pass tanit rcc jusqu'au 15 novembre
mais le cas échéant on a appris que le
pass sanitaire pouvait aussi permettre
de fréquenter des lieux et bien en toute
sécurité les bonnes non ça veut dire que
vous n'excluez pas d'imposer le passé
année terre dans les stations de ski à
noël pour les mains ça ou inversement
même en quatrième en cas de quatrième
vague vous garderiez on a
regardé les boîtes de nuit elles ont
rouvert cet été avec le pass inter donc
si les boîtes de nuit ont rouvert je ne
comprendrais pas que nos télécabine
puisse pas rouvrir donc très clairement
nous on se met en ordre de marche pour
pouvoir est bien préparé cette saison on
la prépare avec les pros je vous le
disais cet après midi assemblée générale
des stations de montagne bientôt le
congrès domaine skiable moi je réactive
une petite structure un petit groupe de
travail montagne pour préparer
l'ouverture de la saison et
avec atout france on met on triple les
moyens dédiés à la promotion de la
montagne française vous avez vu
d'ailleurs la confiance des acteurs
puisque une ligne du royaume uni
desservant les alpes a été remise en
place lignes de ferroviaire donc
tout ça pour dire que on se prépare à
cette saison
clairement les stations de ski resteront
ouvertes cet hiver avec pas sanitaire si
les pmi est encore là sans pas sénateur
si l'épidémie écoutez sur les modalités
encore une fois ce sera le justement le
travail à faire et que tous les acteurs
dans le groupe montagne mais ça va mais
je touche du bois je touche du bois
parce que encore une fois ils ont dû
d'ailleurs abréger leur saison 2020
fermer un peu avant souvenez-vous au 14
mars 2021 2000 l'hiver à 2020 n'a pas pu
être tenus alors on a mis en place le
plan à venir montagne au delà des
mesures d'urgence pour les aider on a
mis des dispositifs à d'aucuns c'est par
exemple sur les remontées mécaniques ses
650 millions d'euros d'indemnisation
avec un dispositif totalement
comment dire sortant de l'ordinaire
qu'on a mis en place avec les acteurs
donc on a été à leurs côtés on va
continuer de l'être et moi ce que je
forme le voeu que effectivement
eh bien nous puissions toutes et tous
dévaler les pentes de nos massifs et
faire en sorte que également les
clientèles européennes retrouvent à
nouveau nos pistes on change d'horizon
mais en restant dans le tourisme anti
réunion nouvelle calédonie polynésie
française où est ce qui vous est ce que
vous est ce que la saison touristique en
est quelles sont les perspectives compte
tenu de la situation sanitaire nord tout
eli effectivement à l'amélioration de la
situation sanitaire on le voit c'est des
situations qui reste complexe la semaine
dernière le parlement était amené à se
prononcer justement sur l'état d'urgence
sanitaire et un certain nombre de
dispositifs donc aujourd'hui on est
avant tout dans le combat pour retrouver
une situation sanitaire la plus normale
possible et c'est vrai que là aussi ces
acteurs pour l'instant il est difficile
pour le coût de leur donner une
visibilité donc déjà un chiffre de
l'impact l'impact sur l'économie
l'impact sur le tourisme pour pour
l'instant en juillet et en août c'est
pas la haute saison par exemple aux
antilles c'est pas la haute saison donc
il y avait des y avait des touristes
présents il a fallu d'ailleurs les
voyagistes les ont fait revenir en
métropole est ce que je veux dire c'est
que on a
dit je veux dire il est fort parce que
ça fait ça fait 18 mois qu'on est dans
cette situation là donc c'est un moment
c'est un cumul qui fait que c'est c'est
compliqué mais on a du coup adaptées
aussi les dispositifs courant juillet
pour faire en sorte que le déclenchement
des dispositifs de fonds de solidarité
etc soit plus souple plus facile dès
lors qu'il y avait des fermetures
administratives et autres dont on
adapter ses outils et puis naturellement
les outre mer seront partie prenante du
plan de reconquête du tourisme que le
président a annoncé lors de son
déplacement dans le lot à saint cirq
lapopie on y travaille et fin octobre
début novembre on sera en situation de
présenter notre copie et donc des
mesures aussi pour les outremers
question politique pour terminer oui
les sénatoriales des français l'étranger
vous avez dit listes en concurrence dont
celle de ségolène royal qui n'a pas été
investi par le parti socialiste à la
salle de la république en marche que
tire samantha cameron
comment quelqu'un le regard portez vous
sur ce sursaut scrutin à venir puisque
on est au sénat alors c'est vrai que ce
scrutin a dû être reportée d'une année
parce que les la désignation des
conseillers des français de l'étranger
qui sont les élus locaux des français de
l'étranger lui même avait dû être
reportée d'un an pour cause de pandémie
au passage je salue la performance de
tous nos postes parce qu on a réussi à
tenir au mois de mai dernier les
élections dans 127 des 130
circonscription alors que parfois le
virus était particulièrement actif donc
merci et respect et donc maintenant
voilà il ya ce scrutin sénatorial ce que
je peux dire c'est que cette majorité se
présenta en public depuis le début être
particulièrement attentifs à la
situation de nos compatriotes établis
hors de france là aussi c'est pas des
mots c'est pas des slogans c'est un plan
de 220 millions d'euros sonnant et
trébuchant comptes est mis en place pour
sauver l'enseignement français à
l'étranger apporter des subventions aux
écoles mettre en place des aides
sociales haddock qui s'appelle sos
qu'ovide pour nos compatriotes qui
étaient les plus fragilisés et puis
c'est également tout un travail qu'on
veut poursuivre pour moderniser cette
action consulaires faciliter la vie de
nos compatriotes il ya un chantier par
exemple sur le numérique sur lequel je
souhaite qu'on puisse avancer dans les
prochains mois c'est le renouvellement
du passeport de façon dématérialisée ça
évite des déplacements au consulat bref
on veut faciliter la vie de nos
compatriotes et celle ci par la
situation sanitaire notamment parlé de
déplacement est ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui
encore des situations blocage selon les
géographies ça peut être compliqué
l'amérique latine encore est dans une
situation où c'est pas simple parfois
l'enseignement reste en distance yale
mais pour autant
on vas y à s'adapter du mieux possible
et en tous les cas ce que je sais c'est
que la liste que tire samantha cameron
avec franck barthélémy sophie suberville
et bien d'autres ce sont des élus de
terrain engagé et qui ont à coeur de
faire entendre la voix des français de
l'étranger au sénat une dernière
question le est-ce que vous avez un oeil
sur le lait performance d'eric zemmour
dans l'est dans l'est dans les
pourcentages il flirte avec les 10% ce
que ça ça vous inquiète pour la
présidentielle vous savez moi je vous
voyez cette possibilité de candidatures
je crois que c'est un peu le candidat de
la peur et avec mes furent acquis avec
ils jouent sur les peurs pour
peut-être dresser une partie de la
france contre l'autre nous on est on est
naturellement pas du tout là dedans vous
l'avez vu le président de la république
c'est un mouvement qui est justement
très large qui rassemble des gens de
tous horizons venant de la droite venant
de la gauche donnant du sens beaune la
société civile est ce qu'on veut c'est
porter cette france unie et pour relever
les défis
la sortie de crise sanitaire la relance
la france en 2030 nous on pense qu'il
faut plutôt y aller de façon positive
optimiste engagé et quand je dis c'est
qu'on peut ça c'est qu'on peut ouvrir
largement les bras il ya un électorat de
droite et du centre-droit qui peut se
reconnaître dans la démarche du
président de la république et dans celle
que j'espère il proposera pour les cinq
ans à venir de la même façon pour un
électorat social démocrate il peut se
reconnaître dans l'action du président
république parce que depuis le début du
quinquennat et on va continuer on a été
par exemple plus ferme sur le régalien
que la droite ne l'a été on l'a dit les
effectifs de police on a été plus
sociaux que les sociaux démocrates avec
un certain nombre de mesures
dédoublement des classes dans les zones
rep etc et puis également pouvoir
d'achat et puis pardon mais on a été
plus dans la protection de
l'environnement que les écolos eux mêmes
regards droite que la droite
est exactement et donc plus efficace que
tout le monde merci
de ouest france stéphane consacré à la
mer des annonces encourageantes pour le
monde maritime c'est à la une de ouest
france aujourd'hui merci beaucoup jean
baptiste lemoyne on vous souhaite un bon
anniversaire
on en profite c'est gentil
[Musique]